hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham episode 5 video a lot of
comic book things happening so we have
the court of owls floating in the
background now we have the order of st.
Dumas which is it was kind of where
Azrael comes from he hasn't come on the
show yet they've actually cast an actor
to do that though and we get to see
Firefly for the first time just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet so so what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to go through you know top 5
WTF moments I'll explain the new
characters in the storylines they're
introducing starting with number 5 the
police task force goes on the warpath so
this whole like this whole introduction
scene with the dudes in their underpants
might have seemed a little weird they're
basically doing Tim Burton's Batman the
music that they use the architecture the
way they frame the scene it's much more
indicative of the style of Tim Burton's
Batman films if you watch the
Christopher Nolan Batman films all that
was filmed in Chicago so it looks a
little bit more normal so the reality of
Gotham is just heightened to a comic
book level in a way that a lot of other
TV shows aren't but this whole raid on
the penguin kind of leads into this
theme of friends being very very
important like the less you have the
more important the ones you do have
become penguin of course always quick to
grovel like penguin versus Theo this is
gonna be an interesting fight this year
wouldn't it be great if penguin is the
one to ultimately take vo down like you
you want Gordon to do it because he's
one of the protagonists of the show but
this is Gotham it's all about the rise
of the villains and you have good
villains and you have bad villains the
penguin even though he's a big bad of
Gotham isn't going to be the biggest
antagonist this season
that's Theo's character it's just like
Captain Cold on the flash Captain Cold
big big villain but he's gonna be an
antihero during legends of tomorrow on
the number 4 though gordon versus date
night
this reaction face probably my favorite
reaction face that he's ever done on the
show I'm gonna get a lot of mileage out
of this I love the idea of Riddler and
Miss Kringle together doing crazy things
but in this scene they're really just
being like a disgustingly happy couple I
felt like there was a lot of comedy to
be had and Miss Kringle asking the
Riddler to go on couples dates so that
you know there's like more witnesses
around we should be hanging around other
people just in case you get a little too
crazy
she might be aware that he is going a
little bit nuts I think she just senses
that he has really weird energy about
him it's like slowly growing on her
he's like a virus or a fungus he just
slowly grows on you on to number three
though Theo
versus Gordon so Theo is trying to get
Gordon's public endorsement because he's
president of the policeman's unions like
the Thea just wants to legitimize
himself in the eyes of Gotham it takes
the entire episode to get there but the
really interesting thing that's going on
is that Gordon has totally drunk the
kool-aid so at some point you know maybe
midseason finale just like expect the
rug to get pulled out from under Gordon
like oh my god I made a deal with the
devil the interesting thing is their
final scene here at the end of the
episode Theo is standing in front of
this like this gargoyle symbol up on the
wall it combines a lot of imagery about
the history of Gotham you don't like
just like the Wayne family name all over
everything in the Dumas family as well
as just looking really sinister like
Theo is the devil so Gordon here is kind
of selling his soul just a little bit on
the number to meet Firefly brand-new
comic book villain on Gotham
Firefly in the comics is a completely
different character there's actually two
male versions of Firefly but all the
tech like all the gear is still the same
so that's fairly true to the comics with
the exception of the jetpack when
Firefly has appeared in the comics and
in the cartoons he has a jetpack that
allows him to fly but for the most part
like the fire gear like though the
weaponry is all the same as it is in the
comics there isn't like a whole lot of
wire work on Gotham yet I mean just
because you know Batman isn't like
jumping from rooftop to rooftop but I
would expect the show to do that at some
point - especially now that we have the
order of st. Tomas who are supposed to
be just like a big group of badasses I
would say if there's an area where
Gotham has been kind of lacking its in
its fight scenes like arrow is a good
example of a TV show you know but people
that don't have superpowers but there's
a lot of really bad as fight scenes I
feel like once Gotham I feel like once
the order of st. Dumas gets into Gotham
we'll start seeing a lot more badass
fight scenes I don't totally mind them
changing the Firefly character from the
comics like it's totally okay to give
the persona to a new character but you
can kind of see that they're trying to
set this actress up to come back like
they gave her this big emotional arc in
the episode showing how her brothers or
her her adopted brothers however you
want to think about it we're treating
her like [ __ ] so she's kind of a
sympathetic villain now Catwoman takes
her under her paw so just expect this
actors to come back like they don't give
an actress this much story if they don't
intend her to use her again so everybody
give Firefly
five I'm sure she's gonna be a lot of
fun on the show she's just another
villain like the penguin somewhat
sympathetic but still doing evil things
still a little bit nutters
and speaking of nutters one of my
favorite parts in the episode though as
part of this Firefly arc was when the
idiot stuck the c4 down his pants and
ran I'm like that was the minute you
knew something was gonna happen to him
like I'm gonna stick this brick of c4
that could blow up a small building
right in front of my junk so that when
the cops shoot me I'll just go splat all
over everything it was actually quite a
bit of comedy violence in this episode
people getting their dicks blown off
getting their eyes gouged out getting
their hands chopped off you guys let me
know how do you feel about violence they
like Game of Thrones level violence when
it's done for comedy like Gotham did it
this week that's when I feel like an
episode has done a really good job like
that's comedy done well when you feel
bad about laughing like ooh that's oh I
shouldn't laugh 10 but finally under my
number one WTF moment the history of
Gotham explained so this is the show
this is actually really cool because it
showed deepening its mythology using the
comics and most of this is true like
flows from court of Alice type stuff now
this week's episode only lightly invoked
the court of Alice it was mostly about
the origins of the order of st. to Ma so
the first half of the season isn't
necessarily culminating to a court of
owls storyline it's culminating towards
an Azrael storyline the order of st.
about this big invasion that they've
been teasing they're kind of like a
religious order version of the League of
Assassins but there are a couple
historical Wayne's that are mentioned in
the episode the one that's typically
credited with building a lot of the
biggest structures in Gotham is Solomon
Wayne he was he was adjudged one of the
early founders of the Great House Wayne
but the earliest Wayne to live in Gotham
was named Nathaniel Wayne and he was he
was like an immigrant that lived in
Gotham when it was just a colony if you
want to read a lot about the history of
the Wayne family and you've already read
the court of owls storyline then read
Batman after final crisis he gets sent
back in time by Darkseid's Omega beams
it just keeps jumping forward so you
keep seeing Wayne's throughout history
but now we know Theo's family are the
Duma and they're on this holy crusade to
redeem Gotham right the wrong that was
done to their family now just explained
Azrael
he is coming on the show they've cast
the actor who
plays him but he's going to be
comparable to Bruce Wayne's age so he
won't be Azrael yet I'm not expecting to
see the suit of Sorrows but we might see
some references and stuff like that that
that's just like some special armor that
the order of st. Dumas constructed it
has some mystical properties derived
from the blood dead of a bunch of
Crusaders but it usually drives the
wearer mad
so just because Gotham hasn't gotten
into magic or mysticism at least like
the way arrow has not expecting to see
any kind of magical artifacts you guys
let me know that like what was your big
WTF moment from the episode was it the
dude getting his dick blown-off was it
butch getting his hand chopped off or is
it the tease of the order of st. Dumas
riding in on Gotham just to beat the
[ __ ] out of everybody the whole episode
was great though I feel like they're
laying a lot of seeds that will
definitely pay off later down the road
hopefully fireflies character won't fall
through the cracks a lot of times shows
that have big cast can lose people in
the mix like by the time you get to the
end of the season it's like oh you know
we meant to do something with this
character but we just we couldn't find a
place for them again
and speaking of finding people again
didn't you think it was funny how
Catwoman was like fish Mooney could
totally come back I feel like that's the
voice of the fandom the people that
liked fish Mooney I was not one of those
people I wasn't a huge fan of her
character but she could totally come
back in some way if Jada pinkett-smith
wanted to come back but what's gonna
happen next is is since it's Sunday I'm
gonna be doing Game of Thrones and
Walking Dead just like normal hopefully
both of those videos will post on time
I'm still in the middle of moving like
I'm still recording videos at my old
apartment while I'm moving into my new
apartment so just be sure to follow me
on Facebook and Twitter to find out when
videos are coming it's gonna be another
week or two before I'm finished moving
and I'll totally do a room to her video
when it's all done but while you wait
for all the videos tonight you can click
here for all my flash and arrow videos
and you can click here to watch the
Jessica Jones trailer again if you
haven't seen that yet thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you